the local election result in northern
ireland sent shockwaves through british
politics voters handed republican party
champaign a historic victory and now for
the first time northern ireland has a
nationalist first minister a first
minister who wants a united ireland that
that means a disunited uk
it's an impossible problem for the uk
government and the nationalists have
seized on him
well i'm joined now by douglas murray
he's written extensively on irish
nationalism so douglas i was gonna uh
and i will get to this talk to you about
the campaign to cancel winston churchill
which you've written brilliantly about
in your superb new book we will get to
that but a lot of breaking news in the
last 24 hours i want to i want to sort
of
bring together with you if i may because
it's all sort of constitutional we have
what's happened in northern ireland with
shin fame becoming the dominant party we
also have the queen cancelling the state
opening of parliament indicating that
she is in a very poor way in terms of
her health
that raises specter of what happens
after the queen what happens to the
monarchy what happens to the united
kingdom with what's happening in ireland
and indeed in scotland what's your take
on all this and you know if you're going
to look forward to say 10 years time
will there be a monarchy will there be a
united kingdom
there'll be a monarchy um i would worry
about the united kingdom in these uh
circumstances as you say piers i mean
the the gains shin fein made in the
local elections historic gains uh should
be troubling to anyone who is like me a
unionist um sinn fein of course is an
irish nationalist party and is as well
in my own view an extremist party and
that isn't uh mere rhetoric you know
mary lou mcdonald the head of shin fein
um has an unbelievable track record i
mean just just that you mentioned nazis
earlier you know there's only one statue
to a nazi in europe and it sits in the
park in dublin sean russell an ira
member who died on a german nazi u-boat
in 1940. there's a statute here in
dublin and shin fein always pay their um
their respects there mary lou mcdonald a
couple of years ago was taken there to
pay her respects she was as it were
bloodied by the more the more militant
wings of shin fein that's totally normal
in shin fein history it's not just that
they were an extremist party in the past
it's that they are in the present it's
not just their irish nationalists that
they are actually extreme irish
nationalists violent irish nationalists
always have been and seem to continue to
be i think it's an incredibly worrying
development as you say alongside the the
uh ongoing success of electorally of the
scots nationalists in in in the north
it's uh it's certainly possible we could
see the breakup for our country it's
it's it's it's something i think
everyone who who recognizes that the
united kingdom has been an enormous
force for good in the world should
really be very worried about we should
be very troubled by that you know the
breaking up into these mini mini
national states within the united
kingdom i think would be a disaster yeah
and you'll write one other thing quickly
of course of course her majesty the
queen has presided over this period of
of peace and and union and i worry
enormously about what comes after us
everyone does yeah well we'll be
debating it later about specifically
about the future of the monarchy but it
is troubling times for people who
believe in united kingdom and great
britain and the monarchy this is a
worrying time and there's no getting
away from that i want to turn to your
book donuts it's a terrific book the war
on the west specifically i want to talk
about the way we're treating historic
heroes not just winston churchill who
was voted the greatest britain of all
the queen would run him a close second i
think
but also american presidents the
founding fathers abraham lincoln and so
on um what you're seeing is the slow
chipping away
of legacies of towering figures uh who i
believe the totality of their
achievement should outweigh the
negatives which go with any human being
of course it talks first of all about
churchill because he's coming under
increasing attack from the woke brigade
you know they portray him as a white
supremacist a racist somebody who did
evil things and shouldn't be considered
great in any shape or form what's your
response to that
yeah they they basically find him guilty
of some victorian attitudes which as you
know if you're born in victorian england
you might well have some victorian
attitudes surprise surprise
if you're born in the 19th century it
turns out you don't have all of 2022's
views um but you're right i mean the the
anti-westernists which is what i think
they are not just work works are sort of
a manifestation of it but the people who
just hate the west
hate the western democracies um they
they keep trying to take down our hero
figures and when i first started
noticing i thought this is very strange
you know normally cultural revolution we
start at the margins and move inwards um
but but they haven't and i think that
this is very telling uh they have come
for winston churchill and are defaming
his reputation and this isn't just the
fringes this isn't just some protesters
uh graffitiing his statues you know it's
it's it's things like the bbc who now
never run a story about churchill
without running a link to a page of the
10 worst crimes of winston churchill
we have we have his own the college
named after him at cambridge running
panels about his alleged racism and much
more and when i noticed this i thought
this is strange and i looked at america
and it's the same thing in america the
same thing of finding people guilty of
being born in the past and having some
attitudes of the past has been used to
justify the removals of statues of the
family the lowest moment for me lincoln
i thought the worst moment for me was
when you had the black lives matter
protests in london and they had to board
up the statues in parliament square of
churchill mandela and gandhi three of
the great figures really of the last
hundred years had to be protected from a
mob that may want to deface them and
scroll horrible graffiti on them
nobody passes this test appears that's a
crucial thing nobody passes the test you
know as as i as i say in the war in the
west you know
even if you even if you take some of the
criticisms of churchill and like all
people he's a bit flawed everybody is
but even if you take those criticisms
you know just does does standing alone
against adolf hitler and being more
important than any other individual uh
for seeing nazism beaten back does that
count for nothing yeah you know so what
if you like to drink on the side so so
what have you said some things that we
don't agree with today that's your count
in the plus side same thing with abraham
lincoln does freeing the slaves count
for nothing apparently not now abraham
lincoln in america has the same
treatment and even gandhi he just
mentioned gets the same treatment nobody
is good enough
for these people who believe that
history starts with them and only they
in 2022 know what's right and wrong
these people of course are doing
something very very wicked very quickly
they are they know that if they take out
churchill they will take out britishness
at a very fundamental level they take
out jefferson and lincoln they've taken
out america it's no less than an assault
at the very fundamentals of our identity
and our right to feel pride in our own
history i completely agree and i think
if you can't acknowledge that human
people are flawed and complicated and
have good and bad size to them whoever
they are nobody is completely saintly
you know i've seen people now trying to
rubbish mother teresa it's like really
really you think the totality of mother
teresa's life is that she's an evil
woman and i'm sure the queen will get it
too when she passes on it's like just
give it a rest you know we're allowed to
have the lady arrows
perfect yeah i mean church the lady
master statue only went up a couple of
years ago exactly and there already
calls for it to come down yeah it's
ridiculous
it's ridiculous
it's a great book the war on the west
great to have you on uh please come back
great love hoping as a guest appreciate
it